foreign
[Music]
there's a lot more to ogres than people
think example example okay
um
ogres are like onions
they stink yes no oh they make you cry
no oh you leave them out in the sun they
get all brown start sprouting little
white hairs no layers onions have layers
ogres have layers onions have layers you
get it we both have layers
once upon a time in a land Far Far Away
there was a princess locked in a tower a
talking donkey a cat in boots and an
ogre that lived in a swamp and that ogre
of course was the one and only Shrek
Dreamworks Animation brought this
lovable green over to the big screens in
2001 and has been a sensation ever since
brought to life by the iconic voice
Talon of Mike Myers giving Shrek his
signature Scottish accent and joined by
the likes of Eddie Murphy and Cameron
Diaz Shrek reimagined a brand of humor
for children and adults alike you a mean
green fight machine together we'll scare
the spit out of everybody that crosses
us ah
that was really scary and if you don't
mind me saying if that don't work your
breath certainly we get the job done
cause you definitely need some something
cause your breath stinks Shrek has since
proven to stand the test of time finding
new life on the internet as well and
although the franchise has produced a
couple of rotten installments to The
Saga it Still Remains a favorite among
its fans being quotable to this day
we'll be right back with the Royal Far
Far Away ball after these messages
hate these ball shows they bore me to
tears flip over to wheel of torture I'm
not flipping anywhere sir until I see
Shrek and Fiona
Wizards on you guys hey just passed me a
buffalo wing not out of your left get
so for this list we wanted to take a
walk deep into the swamp and dig up the
best moments this Series has to offer
and there were plenty to choose from
also if you haven't gotten around to
this fairy tale yet this might be the
part where you quote unquote run away as
this is your official spoiler warning
for all things Shrek so let's peel back
some onions and cook up some waffles as
we count down our list of the best Shrek
moments
foreign
[Music]
number 10 The Frog King dies Shrek III
Shrek and Fiona reign as prince and
princess of the Kingdom Far Far Away
Shrek attempts to serve as king region
while Fiona's father is sick during the
middle of the night the two are called
to King Harold's bedside to find a dying
Frog King in a very unorthodox way that
can only be expected in the world of
Shrek the king gives his last wishes
before dying again and again and again
aside from you there is only one
remaining air
really
who is he that his name is
what's his name what's his name is
[Music]
his name is Arthur Arthur
[Music]
oh
dude what's right
number nine fairy tale creature auction
Shrek
Lord Farquaad of the kingdom of duloc
has decree all fairy tale creatures
fugitives and has banish him from his
lands as a result dozens of famous fairy
tale creatures are being rounded up and
sold for a few Shillings of silver among
the group of witches dwarves and little
wooden puppets were introduced to the
iconic talking donkey his owner tries to
sell him to farquaad's guards but donkey
still has a few tricks up his hoof well
I've got a talking monkey right well
that's good for 10 Shillings if you can
proven oh I go ahead little fella
well oh he just said he's just a little
nervous he's really quite a chatterbox
you bone-headed dog I've heard enough
guards no no he talks he does
I can talk I'd love to talk I'm not
talking is dancing or it's all
get her out of my sight no no I swear
he can talk that's right fool now I'm
applying talking donkey you might have
seen a house fly maybe even a Superfly
but I bet you ain't never seen a donkey
fly
number eight dinner with Dad Shrek 2.
Trek Fiona and Donkey returned to
Fiona's home Kingdom a far far away for
a wedding celebration in their honor
much to their dismay Fiona's parents
King Harold and queen Lillian learned
that Fiona's married Shrek and is chosen
to stay in ogre tensions come to a head
over family dinner as Shrek's ogreness
becomes painfully obvious around the
delicacy of fine dining King Harold
chose his disapproval for Shrek if not
from his signature father-in-law then
from his many outbursts and criticisms
that eventually sent Shrek over the edge
and ignite a full-blown dinner face off
between the two foreign
[Music]
I could expect from you would be ogres
yes not that there's anything wrong with
that right Harold oh no no of course not
that is assuming you don't eat your own
dad oh no we usually prefer the ones
who've been locked away in a tower Shrek
please I only did that because I love
her oh hi daycare or Dragon guarded
Castle you wouldn't understand you're
not her father
foreign
number seven Fiona fights Monsieur Hood
Shrek
after rescuing Princess Fiona from the
dragon guarded Castle Shrek and Donkey
escort her back to duloc to meet her
Suitor Lord Farquaad following a rough
start Shrek and Fiona finally start to
grow more fond of each other and it
seems an unexpected romance may be
blossoming but while the three are
walking through the woods the Mary
Bandit Monsieur Hood interrupts the
Union by swinging in and grabbing
Princess Fiona Hood begins in
excessively exaggerated musical
introduction threatening to rescue Fiona
and kill Shrek just as it seems the
group are in trouble Fiona amazingly
goes full Matrix on them and fights off
the bandits herself
keep your eyes on me boys cause I'm
about Tuesday
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
shall we
hold the phone
number six Are We There Yet Shrek 2.
Shrek and Fiona have been summoned by
her parents to the Kingdom of Far Far
Away to celebrate their wedding Shrek
has reluctantly accepted to make the
trip joined by the one and only donkey
if you've ever had to take a road trip
with your annoying cousin that won't
stop talking you can only imagine what
Shrek and Fiona are in for having donkey
in the carriage with them as Shrek
slowly struggles to keep his nerve
foreign
are we there yet no
[Music]
are we there yet not yet
hey are we there yet
well we there yet no ah Are We There Yet
yes really no are we there yet no are we
there yet no we are not are we there yet
no
Are We There Are We There Yet hey that's
not funny hey that's really interesting
really amateur
see this is
all right you're lost I'm gonna just
stop talking finally
but this is taking forever Shrek and
ain't no in-flight movie or nothing the
Kingdom of Far Far Away donkey that's
where we're going far far
away all right all right I get it
I'm just so darn bored well find a way
to entertain yourself
number five Shrek scares the villagers
Shrek is just a misunderstood Green Ogre
who really enjoys his privacy he's
content living a peaceful life in a
swamp as long as he is left alone
however the neighboring villagers have
other plans now with a price on his head
the villagers ready themselves to hunt
down and capture Shrek from his home but
this isn't the first time Shrek has had
to deal with pesty Town's folk he
reminds them why you don't mess with
ogres and really gives them something to
fear in all his green Glory
do you know what that thing could do to
you yeah he'll grind your bones for its
bread yes well actually that would be a
giant now ogres wow they're much worse
they'll make a suit from your freshly
peeled skin no they'll shave your liver
squeeze the jelly from your eyes
actually it's quite good on toys
I want you
right
oh
God
[Applause]
turn away
[Laughter]
number four princesses unite Shrek III
Charming has taken over the Kingdom of
Far Far Away he has imprisoned Fiona and
her mother with them or donkey puss Snow
White Cinderella Sleeping Beauty
Rapunzel and Doris the ugly stepsister
learning that Prince Charming means to
kill Shrek Fiona is determined to forge
and escape the other princesses however
are unconvinced as they are more
comfortable playing the Damsel in
Distress but with little motivation for
Mom by breaking through the wall with
her head the princesses band together
and use their magical abilities to fight
the guards break into the castle and
rescue a very helpless ogre in distress
all right everyone
we need to find a way out now you're
right ladies assume the position
what are you doing
to be rescued you've got to be kidding
me well what do you expect us to do
we're just four
I mean three super hot princesses two
circus freaks a pregnant ogre and an old
lady hmm
excuse me old lady coming through
[Music]
mom well you didn't actually think you
got your fighting skills from your
father did you excuse me I think there's
still one more
hmm
why don't you just lie down
[Music]
okay girls from here on out
we're going to take care of business
ourselves
[Music]
number three I am Puss in Boots Shrek 2.
King Harold has sought to handle his
ogre problem in Shrek by asking the
mysterious Bandit Puss in Boots for help
puss tracks him down in the woods and
attacks Shrek before easily being
captured by the ogre puss pleads his
case and reveals that he was hired by
King Harold to get rid of Shrek in an
attempt to persuade the gang to allow
him to accompany them to the home of the
Fairy Godmother puss unleashes his most
powerful secret weapon
stop okay
join the club we've got jackets on my
owner I am obliged to accompany you
until you have saved your life that you
have spare me mine I'm sorry the
position of annoying talking animal has
already been taken let's go Shrek
Shrek
[Music]
heck oh come on donkey look at him in
his Wee Little Boots you know how many
cats can wear boots honestly oh let's
keep them say what
ah oh listen he's putting oh so now it's
cute oh come on Donkey lighten up oh I
should lighten up
number two welcome to do lock Shrek
Shrek and Donkey have arrived at the
Kingdom of duloc to confront Lord
Farquaad for banishing all fairy tale
creatures into Shrek Swan upon arriving
at the castle save one Farquaad mascot
they find a place to be completely
deserted the two are welcomed instead by
a small animatronic sand that delivers
the most iconic welcoming musical number
in the entire franchise
hey look at this
[Music]
Shine Your Shoes wipe your face
[Music]
wow
let's do that again no no no no no no
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
do the roar Shrek Forever After
track the green terrifying ogre is now
Shrek the green full-fledged Family Man
Shrek and Fiona celebrating their
children's first birthday and have
thrown a large party however Shrek can't
help but feel he might not be cut out
for family life as the chaos of his
children and the party begin to test his
patience and his nerve to make matters
worse a very eager Shrek fan and his
bratty kid pester Shrek to do his famous
ogre Roar overcome by stress and at his
Wit's End Shrek might just give him what
he wants
hey I believe you promised my son a roar
roar I don't like it pegs we need
another cake
are there any cupcakes
everything's gonna be okay
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hey everybody I have found another kid
are you okay
[Music]
you're a girl Dragon Shrek
Shrek and Donkey have arrived at the
dragon guarded Castle to rescue Princess
Fiona after crossing the lava Bridge
they're looking for the highest room in
the tallest tower as Legend has it
that's where Fiona is imprisoned Shrek
sends donkey to look for some stairs but
inadvertently finds Dragon guarding the
castle instead terrified donkey makes a
run for it but is quickly cornered by
the gigantic beast in a desperate
attempt to save his life donkey turns to
his greatest resource his mouth and
begins flattering and flirting with the
dragon eventually wooing her enough so
she takes him prisoner instead
come on
[Music]
oh no no
oh what's large teeth you have
me I mean white sparkling teeth I know
you've probably heard this all the time
from your food but you must bleach or
something cause that is one dazzling
smile you got there and do I detect a
hint of minty freshness and you know
what else you know what else you're
you're a girl Dragon oh sure I mean of
course you're a girl Dragon cause you're
just reeking up feminine beauty uh
what's the matter with you you guys
man I'd really love to stay but you know
I'm a I'm an asthmatic and I don't know
if it'll work out you're gonna be
blowing smoke rings and stuff
bird explosion Shrek
Shrek donkey and Fiona are well on their
way back to duloc after a good night's
rest and successfully keeping her secret
Fiona wakes up refreshed she takes to
the woods in Pinnacle princess fashion
singing and dancing as she strolls she's
joined by a small bird who begins
singing along with her what starts as a
magical duet quickly turns into a
dramatically intense Sing-Off with
hilariously disastrous consequences at
least Fiona manages to walk away with
some breakfast from an otherwise tragic
situation
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and finally number one gingerbread
interrogation Shrek
we enter the kingdom of duloc led by the
insatiable and arrogant Lord Farquaad a
very small man with a very large ego
Farquaad enters his dungeon where he has
captured the fabled gingerbread man
prisoner and has done The Unthinkable by
taking his legs he interrogates the
gingerbread man to reveal the location
of the other fairy tale creatures so he
can capture them gingerbread man
reluctantly submits but what is meant to
be an interrogation soon becomes an
absurd nursery rhyme instead as
gingerbread asks do you know the muffin
man
hahaha
um
run run run as fast as you can you can't
catch me I'm the gingerbread man you're
a monster I'm not a monster here you are
you and the rest of that fairy tale
trash poisoning my perfect world now
tell me where are the others
I've tried to be fair to you creatures
now my patience has reached its end tell
me or I'll
gum drop button all right then who's
hiding them
okay
tell you
do you know the muffin man the muffin
man the muffin man yes I know the muffin
man who lives on Drury Lane well
man
I'm married to the muffin man
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]